well it's just after 8 30 so we will
start and welcome
welcome to those on live stream uh we
also have chair bruce robertson
and jane
as well
zooming in as bruce is on
zoom then he has asked me to chair the
meeting i believe we have a quorum
a note apologies from lindsey mckenzie
alex crackit and ian pottinger are there
any other apologies
it would appear to be none someone
please move those apologies thank you
vicar thank you darren always in favor
please say aye aye
against
abstentions carried thank you
uh note any updates and declarations of
interest
appear to be none just remind
all to update your
uh interest register
for any changes
all right if we can move to the minutes
of the previous
meetings first one held on 29th of
september 2021
thank you darren
thank you nobby all those in favor
please say i
against the abstentions carried thank
you
next is the extraordinary
meeting on the 3rd of november
thank you rebecca
thank you darren all those in favor
please say aye
against abstentions carried thank you
and lastly the extraordinary meeting
held on the 15th of november
thank you nobody thank you darren always
in favor please say aye
against abstentions carry thank you
geez i'm just moving paper copy as my
electronic
innocent here
isn't working
if we move on to the working on working
together
our paper
so just before we do that
just uh thank you michael just advised
that we have major uh
late item which will be um
discussed under public excluded move
that it be accepted for the reasons
given
thank you darren i think you'll be here
all those in favor please say hi
again abstentions carried thank you very
much
also note that there isn't a
a minor uh late item to public excluded
2 which is a verbal update on the end
report
that's accepted
so we'll accept that at the
in the same
resolution thank you
all right working on working together
jane
bruce
james the better spokesperson for sure
i can lead off thank you um ross this is
a reasonably short report this time um
as it says in the summary the main focus
as it usually is for risk and assurance
is the the financials and the risk
profile which i'll talk to when we get
there
um it talks about the the key tasks for
this project early next year been two
things
reviewing a final review of the project
and then a legacy report
and just moving to the bottom of page
one
it
you'll see there that we have the the
one pager
working on working together framework
attached as appendix a
um it's useful to keep referring to that
because everything
links back
to that um
outline
um
so if there's no questions so far just
moving on to the budget
[Music]
i guess the focus is the budget going
forward
we have recast how it looks
um and just to
remind everybody we've been delivering
well within budget and we anticipate
that that will continue
there's been no change to the budget for
external appointees but we do note that
going forward their presence will be
less
so we anticipate
that we'll deliver under budget
there too
the working groups have now concluded
apart from um
one group which is being ref we
i shouldn't say reformed it's been
reconstituted
um to support the mayor
the the big items in there are support
for councillors and the importance there
is picking up on all the work that was
done last year and making sure it's
embedded in council
and you'll see
several items in there where we see a
particular focus
and then we have the independent advice
and support and finally the review
activities
there's some notes at the bottom which i
think that are self-explanatory and uh
just to
the only final report remark i'd make is
the same one as at the beginning we do
anticipate and i think michael morris is
probably there i can't see him but
michael will be there but we anticipate
that this will be delivered well within
budget
maybe a pause if there's any comments or
questions uh
nobody you could have yeah right forgot
two um sorry for being a bit slow there
on on the first one
which is at the bottom of page one that
jane made reference to um
um covert 19 and and the report there
says it identifies 96 individual
positions and council that would need to
be double waxed i understand that figure
is much higher than that
i think we're on different pages one
i've looked at
it's actually page 20 i was talking
about sorry about that i looked at the
wrong number so nobody we're still on
working on working together
talking about
the framework um my apologies for the
wrong page number
so you probably
might be ahead of yourself with
questions is that right yes i wouldn't
want to be there
you've got any questions are there any
other questions
it's just just a reflection on on the
comment that jane made about the uh
supporting the mayor's group and just an
update to that
um at our last meeting i think it was
the last
full council meeting i undertook to
approach councillor abbott to see
whether he would uh chair a meeting
in relation to the five elected members
who said they were prepared to have an
informal group that supported the mayor
given that that
commitment by those members was prior to
the media statement that referred to
them as bullies there has been some
unease now but he will still in the new
year attempt to
have a meeting with those five
members but i think we will have some
reduction in the number as well
right note that comment thanks
are there any other questions
the risk the risk register
um
we have three closed risks for low
three low to medium and one medium
so we are fairly stable
in terms of risk and much reduced from
this time last year perhaps two risks to
emphasize the medium one which is number
nine
um about losing focus on the foundations
we need to keep our eye on that one
and number 11
it is low to medium
but we want to make sure that i think
we've called it
um
complacency
through the transition period
we've made good gains today we've got a
plan and place to capture them
but
we mustn't get complacent or lose
momentum
so these were the key points on the risk
register if anybody wants to
query or has got any questions maybe a
pause
there would appear to be none none
and the next steps we've talked about
really the two things are reviewing
finally how the project has gone
and writing a legacy report which we
will
[Music]
present to council
and
they will
consider that with a view to it going to
dia and a request
for a response from dia given that we
commenced this project with a letter
from die way back in august
2020.
and that's all for me
i just said one question if it's okay
please
go for it perhaps it's to
the members of the cheers group
um and i'm just thinking about uh your
point jane well made about the
risk of complacency
and i don't think we're overly
high on that risk
but i'm just wondering we are going into
the christmas break
and political leadership is important to
continuity over that period
um have the chairs group
work through now what are the leadership
arrangements over the holiday break
yes
excuse me mr chair i can come forward
and just i can advise the committee that
the leave arrangements for councillors
are currently being compiled and the
arrangements for cover will be discussed
at the chairs meeting next week
thank you
exactly i just think you can see what
i'm trying to get at is working on
working together is about good
governance leadership we've got a period
when we're probably
well hopefully many of us are on
vacations we have to think those ones
through as well thank you
thank you
jane thank you for your work uh
and
could i please uh someone to move that
we received the working on working
together project report
thank you nobby have a second to thank
you darren
all those in favor just before you did
knobby is that where you wanted your
questions for the second half of that
report around that
no no no no no
all those in favor please say hi
again abstention is carried thank you
very much
merry christmas everybody i'll leave now
thank you jane
uh health and safety uh risk update
peace
that's fine i'll take
[Music]
just the again the issue on page one
which is on board books 28
it says
the assessment assessments have
identified 96 positions but
is it is it more than that now
mr yes it is more than that
at the
bpp committee last week the report
indicated that approximately 160 roles
have been assessed as being homeless
thank you
obviously you have a further question
i've got some other questions in
relation to how we're dealing with um
what's this whole covered thing is this
the appropriate place to potentially
raise it or do it i would suggest that
as given that as health and safety sure
and i think
so um just a couple of things three
things probably for me
um
the first thing is i notice that staff
don't scan into this chamber
um
and while they may not
be required to under protocols it
doesn't sit well with the community that
see
their members having to scan in
elected members having to scan in and
the media had to scan it but the staff
walk in and out of the place
so i just flagging that because from a
public decision that doesn't sit well
that they're having rules forced onto
the public
and we're not abiding by them ourselves
now we'll have different opinions about
that but it's just a public procession
i've had quite a bit of feedback on it
so leave that part up for one issue
uh the other issue is that i just want
to reflect that what the chief executive
just told me because i think it's a
really positive thing i think the media
and the public need to hear this
the the position of the organization is
that
anybody who
goes to splash palace the library of
hewakaturi and is asked to present a
passport
will only interface with staff that have
passports as well
so we're not having a different set of
standards on the outside i think it's
really positive we've taken it and happy
if claire can confirm that because
there's been some unease and it was an
editorial couple days ago that
flagged up that we were
forcing conditions onto the public to
enter our building but our own staff
weren't reciprocating on the other side
of that i guess that internal external
boundary
and i guess the other
issue is the issue of our obligations
under pcbu
which is uh internal stuff for clear but
something that i'm quite interested in
because it's it doesn't relate so much
to the
external internal boundary it deals with
the internal issues that we have within
the boundary
so for argument's sake um somewhere
along the line we'll have to deal with
the issues
of how we safeguard staff who work in
the building
from staff who are in the building who
may not be vaccinated that's one issue
and the issue is i've had some feedback
from people who are internally employed
who are immunized compromised and
they're worried
and
they're doing it now the the counter
argument to that as well you've worked
with your colleagues for the last six
months what's changed
well what's changed now is we've got
another tool available to us in the kit
like the many tools that we've got and
should we be using it they're not saying
that we should use it now
but it's if you don't get your house in
order i guess
and know where your risks are under the
health and safety at work act
then by the time you have the risk it's
too late
and so we've had
some very spasmodic guidelines from
the government and from the privacy
commission as well about needing to have
a policy in place
when you're dealing with staff you can't
just knee-jerk and make a mandatory
decision you need to have work through
potential risks work through how you'll
respond to that put it in the policy put
it to staff so everybody knows well in
advance
so again i'm just signaling there not
nothing to be done right now but if we
get an outbreak given this building
is a very large potential spreader and
non-vax people are potentially greater
spreaders than vax people
how we would deal with that um and
whether we're giving any thought to that
in advance
and how we deal with the internal issue
of
i'm working here i don't know who the
non-vex people are
and i've got some health issues
which makes me worry so i guess these
are the three issues
so you just want those comments noted
i'll be rather than responding to
oh i'd like to hear from clarence or her
staff mr chairman on all three of those
i think it'd be useful for the public to
understand that we are giving effect to
the legislative framework that's been
put in place
and if that provides a different
requirement
for the public as opposed to staff
then i'm sorry for the confusion but i
can only work with within the framework
that the government has provided
so the first thing is that all staff
coming into this building are identified
by the use of this
um staff id
and
i'd like to be really careful about what
we individually believe about health
advice
as opposed to that which the government
has access to which we are unaware of
and which we are unable to
confirm or consider otherwise what we do
know quite factually is that
not controlling but being able to know
where people have gone and who they have
interacted with is one of the best tools
available
and so staff moving around this building
actually effectively sign in to each and
every floor including access to the
first floor
second thing is that
there are a number of tools that
counselor clark has referred to and we
are already employing some of those such
as additional cleaning such as the
wearing of masks such as hand sanitisers
councillors may have noticed a
difference in the way that food is
presented provided we are doing things
that ensure that there is a greater
level of care
for staff around the building
the third thing i would say is that we
have as required
taken into account
the questions that mb put in front of
all employers if they wish to and
considered that in relation to
roles who are
at higher risk
of encountering covet 19 than others
i i made the statement last week at the
committee
excuse me that all of the lt was
vaccinated not as a result of a
requirement but as a result of choice
but other than that my obligations to
provide privacy and indeed to recognise
that most people still go to the
supermarket or the petrol station
both of which are locations which you
cannot require back certificates for
so we are really working hard to make
sure that we've looked at where staff
are at greater risk and need to be
vaccinated
i think that we need to recognize human
behavior comes into this and so i've
given councillor clark a comment
and he asked
can you give me an assurance that any
back certificate holder attending the
library splash palace in kwaka touri
will not come into contact with any
non-vaccinated staff
i want to be really careful with the
language and say we have assessed the
public facing positions at those
locations as needing vaccinated staff so
that should be the assurance that he is
looking for
we are working through any employment
issues that has thrown up but i just
want to make the point that we are
as always dealing with people
and i'll just add that these discussions
are happening in
numerous businesses um you know
including my own and you know i refer
uh
any of our staff or inclines to the mb
framework which has been which is very
comprehensive and that would be useful
to be
circulated and also the ministry health
guidelines
and we follow those thank you mr chair
we provided those last week you'll see
that we've given full effect in terms of
the mask wearing within this chamber
unless you are speaking
i would point out that the ombudsman has
provided some advice on the matters that
should be taken into account when making
regulatory policy and the introduction
of vaccine certificates is a matter of
regulatory policy
uh and the guidance is forever being
refined
thank you darren you hit her nothing's
been answered on
uh nigel is that a pen up or is it
probably the only other thing i want to
ask ned to the report is that anything
um you're experiencing or needs notified
around antisocial behavior that your
staff might be experiencing ah thank you
mr chair i think that the behaviour we
are experiencing
is uh an indicator of the level of
anxiety and possibly anger that people
are feeling in the community
even a peaceful protest held here on
monday or tuesday
resulted in staff feeling very
uncomfortable as a result of protesters
photographing their faces photographing
their name badges
we are certainly finding that people are
on what you would
refer to as on a shorter fuse
and we have
brought into the organization armour
guard security guards at
splash palace and the library
we're constantly reviewing the need for
that in the downstairs at the customer
service centre
thank you
nobody did you
well just just some reflections i guess
personal reflections for me on what
claire just said i don't want to be seen
to be having any argument with her
um
i'm pleased about the uh
three locations because that's one of
the big issues that the community asked
about and that was the
part of the editorial two days ago as
well um i still struggle with the
concept that staff
don't vex i don't
scan into this when everybody else is
here does have to scan them
given that we've got some
elected members who are uneasy about
that some are compromised themselves
some have partners who are compromised
it's not a big ask to ask staff to scan
in to make sure that they are all waxed
chief executive said the elt is but
we've got more than elt
in this chamber
um
and that's that's not a big ask for me
and again that that comes back to not
just the internal external boundary but
it comes to some elect the members are
uneasy now that we're not using that
tool to safeguard elected members as
well
um so some think about that would be
helpful i think
yes darren
thanks chad just
reflecting on that and and trying to
bear in mind
that as an employer
we need to be cognizant
or the organization needs to be
cognizant of the right to privacy of
members of the public
the only way
past that and bearing in mind that for
staff this is their workplace for the
rest of us it is it is not
i don't
have a vaccine passport scanned every
time i go to my workplace but i do
use the the tracer app
to maintain privacy the only way we
could do it is by actually having all
staff that are in here at the moment
zooming in
that's the only way you could maintain
their privacy around the vaccination
status
thank you
so
two issues in response to that um
privacy commission has already given us
advice that
any employer
and this includes the pcbu obligations
as well under health and safety at work
act
has a right to ask
their workers is what he referred to not
employees because elected members are
deemed to be workers under that act
that we
the
organisation can ask anybody including
elected members where they're vaccinated
those members or workers can refuse to
comment which is there right the
property which
darren's referring to
and then after that the organization has
a right to then consider them to be
non-vaxxed
i'm not asking to find out who the staff
are not not backed all i'm suggesting is
if they if they're not backs they should
zoom in
as elected members are now being
required to do
so if the elected member doesn't have a
vaccination passport
they have to zoom in and quite rightly
so
i don't want elected members to elect
not to be here in person because it
reduces ability to debate the issues and
to deal with democracy purely because
they're nervous about
what's sitting in the room around them
now i know we've got one that will zoom
in for forever and a day now but we've
got a couple that are considering
staying awake and i think that's
unfortunate
andrew you wanna um
just to draw it back i suppose the the
key question to uh
as to whether or not there is a
requirement uh to understand staff's uh
vaccination status hinges on the risk
assessment and i suppose that's where
the
perceived conflict i won't call it a
true conflict but where the perceived
conflict arise until you have a risk
assessment saying that it is necessary
for staff to be vaccinated to attend
here then we have no reason to ask the
question um and that's that's
the bottom line
um there is no other requirement that
requires the vaccination certificate for
staff to attend from the chambers
thank you
well
this is where the public might think
that we're
a group of fools
and that we're inconsistent in our
approach and this is what feedback i'm
getting so i've got to have a passport
to go to the library
and the staff that face me across that
library counter will be vaccinated
that's insurance that
chief executive government that's a
that's a great result
what andrew just said was
public are here today
media here today we're here today we've
got to be vaccinated by risk assessment
to be here
um
and yet
staff who attend don't have to
get there i don't know i know i know
we'll play
we'll play some um
some wording around whether there's been
an assessment here or whether it was a
decision made by councillors but that's
not what the public sector they just see
one rule for one and one rule for the
other we can't help the lack of
understanding
mr chair the
risk assessment for this chamber or the
need for a vaccine certificate for this
chamber and indeed for the library is
not as a result of a risk assessment it
is as a result of a council decision
council is free to make that decision
however i still need
to
effectively manage within the rule of
the law that i have in front of me and
that says
that if this is the staff member's
workplace and i do not deem them to be
at high risk
then i have no requirement to make them
double vacced
thanks
nigel thank you to eugene i guess the
challenge we have is the covert can't
determine who is high risk and who's not
yeah
that comes down to
luck
to be honest and that's the point i
stick with and i've been quite outspoken
in many ways in the sense of where we
should be at
i except councillor clark's point i also
accept clears the points that we've made
and it's just about
in the world that we're living if we can
be as proactive as we can because we all
know
going forward that we have some
challenges
rather than being reactive we have the
opportunity of being proactive and i
just go back to the point covered is not
going to determine who's at high risk
we can we can minimise without doubt and
our venue the one i work in obviously
it's it's like this one
just you know up to 12 000 people a week
to come through it we are highly
vulnerable
in that particular venue
um and not quite so much here but i
accept both arguments without a shadow
of a doubt
um so it's just a matter of
i guess
making sure that we are protecting and
taking
in my opinion taking a really positive
and proactive
viewpoint to what is going to be a major
challenge going forward
exactly it's not a game of table tennis
but i would just say that it's my job
to make sure you are aware of the
relevant considerations
and one of those relevant considerations
that has only come out in the last week
is the ombudsman's guidance
on the basis that regulatory policies
are based on sound evidential basis
it is not local government's job to
determine health
matters
uh that is the government's job
so i continue to work within the context
i have
thank you i'll draw that too
just a final comment here um
a quick question
if it's relevant
well it is relevant because i think one
other thing that we haven't
identified but we all know as there's a
huge amount of
inconsistency here
and i i just can't see how we put at
risk
um non-veg people being in this chamber
on the assumption that they have some
sort of privacy rights
where in fact what we're struggling with
is is a reputation in our community and
wider than that that across all the
councils there's so much inconsistency
it's embarrassing i mean you just got to
look what they've done in dunedin what
they've done tim's coromandel i mean and
and we're which constantly challenged by
the water you just blanket across and
make everybody require now i didn't take
that position so as as i've said declare
in others i think that was an
overreaction
but i just i still don't get the
the privacy it doesn't breach the
person's privileges just to ask them to
zoom in from an adjoining room all right
no comment so yeah i think this will
just be a
an evolving process
uh and we would look forward to clearer
guidelines coming from wellington i'm
happy to answer any other questions
relating to the help mr chair
are there any
uh not a question just a comment um but
i participated in this site visit to the
stead street um wharf and um got a bit
of a health and safety rundown from um
lee
and he's got a very comprehensive
document that he's using when he does
this
the site safety
health and safety visits
and it was really good to see that
that's evolving and happening and to be
able to participate in that so i see
from the report that councillors will
have the opportunity to attend other
such visits next year would really
encourage everyone to
get involved in that and see how it
works and get that health and safety
mindset
thank you can i make a quick comment
say thank you to lee for a report which
gives me a much better sense indeed of
what you're hunting at bets which is the
over the overview the approach that we
are taking generally
nobby you've talked about pcbus and i
must confuse these are quite concerning
results in our in our combined pcbus
trucks tipping over
no risk assessment
etc as we've seen there that is worrying
and um so look i i will appreciate that
one or two of those under investigation
and i think we should
[Music]
just just a reflection on on what beck
said or reinforcement of that i think
it's very pleasing that we've
uh got a new focus on health and safety
um and the way it's being has been
operated that different eyes are coming
from different sections involving
different layers so just leave it as i
say oh sorry
you might have to repeat it
carry on who
yeah i'm just going to say i thought
it's an interesting development within
the organization that we've got um a new
focus and that we've got people
cross-pollinating from one
division i guess to another because it's
very easy when you live in your own your
own world for a period of time that you
get very complacent with things and
don't see things that others might see
so yeah that's that's uh
i've got some nicely text down the side
of my page on it thank you
if there are another comments uh could
uh someone plead to be moved the
that we received the health and safety
risk update thank you rebecca
have a second i think please
thank you
darren all those in favor please say hi
against abstentions carried thank you
very much
uh project management office status
report lee
welcome
i will take you the reporters read is
there anything you wish to
the report uh add will see it's changed
since the last one and the next report
we've seen in a few months time will
change again with a bit more of a risk
question
there we go sorry
uh so yeah the report will just keep on
evolving um as we find better ways to
report to the organization and look at
risks
probably only thing i'd like to add to
that
thank you are there any questions
questions for lee
it would appear to be none you've got
off pretty low oh sorry
i've got to come in that slide on
on page 35 of board books
um
it shows the museum funding in there as
being
um
having some discrepancies in there and
when it says um
the original budget for the museum was
roughly 39 million
and now it's up to 54 million
um
just want to make sure that we're
comparing apples with apples here
because i know the original 39
didn't involve some other funding that
was being sought or potentially going to
be sold it was just that was the money
we were putting in
yeah so the report just shows the
our commitment yeah sure yeah okay thank
you
all right if there's no further
questions could i please uh someone
please uh move that we received a report
thank you nobby
thank you nigel all those in favor
please say hi all right
against abstentions carried thank you
performance report for three months
patricia welcome
[Music]
good morning so i'll take this report as
read as well this is the quality report
that's already been to ppp back in
november
and
um
just pull up
that one
um
but the one thing is to note that we've
decoupled the treasury report from this
and it's part of a separate report
you'll get later in the agenda
thank you yes i know that's been to ppe
already so uh
are there any further comments or
questions on the report
move it's received
thank you darren thank you nigel all
those in favor please say aye
against abstentions carried
uh bruce has just messaged that he's now
lost connection with us so he will try
and reconnect
move on
uh patricia you've got the next one the
next one um jamie can't make it down
he's dealing with auditors this morning
um
[Laughter]
um
so this is a report on the
assumptions that we're proposing to use
for the 2223 annual plan
the proposal is that we use the same
assumptions from the ltp with the
exception of those that are included in
the report
on page 73 of
wood books
and that's mainly around water reform
where we still are a little uncertain
though unless we have some legislation
as it is yesterday
of potential legislation but it's
inflation um and interest which are
probably the ones where there's been the
most movement
um recently that we're looking at more
closely
and the asset revaluation will also need
us to reconsider
and we'll discuss that further later
thank you
are there any questions
nobody
um
so on page 75 of um
board books
let me get there yep
on on the issue of diversity
um
it refers to um
maori population
being 17 to 19
um i've done some recent research on
that and
uh new zealand statistics are saying
that the population
size in the south island is 9.8 not 17
to 19 that that figure potentially is a
national figure as opposed to
one that impacts on us
so just flag that because i think it's
important that when we're dealing with
issues of
diversity that
um the
maori population statistics vary
significantly across territory
authorities
yeah i'll write that down yeah thank you
councillor and just the last one was
on page
85
i see in there that we've got
assets and activity levels there's
reference there to the forestry assets
valued on an annual basis so is that
the forestry company which is now
gone i understand or going or is that
the residual forestry assets that we
still have beyond what was in ic
fl
it's beyond right so it is a sandy point
first
thank you
thank you
there will appear to be no other
questions
so
please ask someone to
receive the in report and note the
assumptions used in the annual plan for
2223
uh year will be updated to reflect the
current interest rate predictions and
construction market impacts
of some of the
rebecca thank you darren thank you all
those in favor please say aye
aye against abstentions carried thank
you
internal audit plan
peter
peter welcome
joining us
again we'll take your uh reporters read
if there's anything you wish to add or
highlight i'd just like to
highlight the sensitive expenditure
review and that there was four
four recommendations out of the
sensitive expenditure review two rated
moderate risk and too low these will be
included in the internal attenuation
program will be monitored and reported
going forward until the actions are
complete
the next part of the report the draft
business assurance plan i'd like to just
point out that we can add up to
additional
two reviews in the next financial year
for 2022 2023
and just for the continuous improvement
program
just note that there's now a continuous
improvement risk scale at table three of
that report
in that we've completed an additional 11
actions
from the four from the deloitte reviews
previously being reported
we currently have four risks
four high risks outstanding
three of those
actions will be completed as part of the
procurement policy that was approved on
tuesday
and the other outstanding one the
delegations is uh under action and
should be completed in the first half of
next year
thank you darren
thanks chad peter i may have just
blanked and missed it for a second but
on the recommendations from deloitte
regarding these um
sensitive expenditure review
uh
are there any actions at any point
because just noting them
doesn't
imply that we're going to do anything um
it's worth sort of got uh patricia to
sit here and uh make comment on those
recommendations council
the both recommendations
are being actioned as part of a
continuous finance
so those recommendations are being
actioned as part of our continuous
improvement in finance
some of them are just requiring we would
prefer to use some system improvements
in that so it's just the time delay um
so there are actions it's not just being
yeah so there are actions um the actions
identified by deloitte had already been
identified by staff great thank you
bobby
three things about that report in
relation to
the credit card usage um it talks uh on
numerous occasions about um
post payment approval so but that's the
nature of a credit card doesn't it you
don't need to use your procurement or
accounts payable system you go out and
you
zap the card you've got authority to do
that and then the authorization comes
after that so
i was a bit unsure about why they
focused on that when they didn't really
give us any examples of
where that might have been
inappropriately used that was the first
thing
they talk also about the one-up approval
but they don't clarify the situation
with the chief executive because
chief executive doesn't have a one-up
she's at the top of the
appendicular as it were and so they
should have clarified that as well that
and i know we do have things in place
for that but not in that report
unfortunately
and the other thing was they talked
about
procurement
processes as opposed to using a credit
card and they gave a couple of examples
of that because i was interested to hear
from patricia whether there's some
greater clarity around where you can use
a credit card
and where you can't
but certainly the issue of the uh
um
the nature of having a credit card it
does allow you to
uh really approve yourself at the time
but then you have to justify it
um patricia thanks councillor um
those comments you correct
that is the nature of them but what they
were suggesting was that people were
using their credit card instead of using
appropriate purchasing processes so
raising of a purchase order getting that
approved in advance
um
on the other points the one-ups uh we
had identified those as well and because
we're using a manual system at the
moment it's harder to pick up
um and that's where we'll look to
improve that sure um
and the last issue is of reference to
need to
uh one of the credit card holders using
the credit card to pay parking fines
that that was a one-off um
thing and uh
we do identify those and we also pick up
personal expenditure as well when you've
got two cars that look the same you pick
up the wrong one so that
michael would you like to add
yes thank you through yourself the chair
i just wanted to address the item in
relation to the ce um side of it uh look
see expenditure in relation to approved
policies that have been
approved by council so that expenditure
is administered by myself to make sure
that it's compliant and within policy um
if there was expenditure outside that
that would definitely be something we
would need to take up to
either through the mayor or through the
council side we have not had anything
that's been outside policy from that
perspective
thank you thank you
i would just add would
in future part of this would we actually
get the list of sensitive expenditure
as well
um
you would normally have got a sensitive
expenditure report this month as well
but um the team have been focused on
doing that in your report so you'll get
a six the next risk insurance will cover
the last three months thank you thank
you
just for you chair i have been citing
some of those
i have been
signing them as well say that i've seen
them
all right there will be appear to be no
further questions
could i ask that we received the
report
on review of sensitive expenditure dated
november 21 note the recommendations
from deloitte relating to the review
receive the icc business assurance plan
for years 22 to 23 and note the internal
audit and continuous improvement program
updates could someone please move that
thank you nigel thank you rebecca all
those in favor please say aye
against abstentions carried thank you
very much
welcome back bruce
sorry about that underneath went down
for some reason
sorry we've nearly finished
yeah i can see there
uh risk management
update
again peter excuse me chad um
some stage will we get to hear what
bruce was
originally raising about the pcbus
was there something bruce you want
uh before you got cut
i'll just uh i'll just keep that video
off on the basis that it might make it
uh uh more useful look i know i was
saying two things one is my appreciation
for an effective health and safety
reward to get a better sense of what's
happening across
the organization the second thing was
those are some concerning incidences or
incidents with the in our combined pcbus
and i think we should be
committee keen to see what is the
outcome of those
um they look preventable
um i mean i guess all accidents are
and i think we should treat those as
significantly been serious for our own
purposes of being and getting assurance
about our health and safety record with
our contractors
thank you thanks
all right
peter
well i'll take the report as being read
um
just as a bit of a verbal update we've
conducted workshops for the five
groups within council these workshops
we've been to build on each team's
understanding of organizational risk
management
to identify some of the key risks for
each group
and to start a pro prioritization
exercise for each of those
moving forward i'll be working with
which each of the group's leadership
teams to develop their risk registers
once these have been approved we'll
migrate them into the pro risk module so
we can start reporting on these
for that
appendix a has an example of the
information available from promet
for each of these risks
are there any comments or questions for
peter
nobby um on page 122 of board books um
the risk register there highlights um a
risk for
our computer systems or information
systems to be breached
um
it went to a recent
zone meetings
[Music]
i think councillor clark just asked
about a risk that came to fruition
so interesting at the zone meeting we
had a presentation by one of the senior
managers and the
company with the exact word but it's
basically the spy agency for new zealand
and what he said was large organizations
like large councils large dhbs need to
do more in this space
these and i've raised this with um with
michael as well that they gave him
the name of an agency and i can't
remember what it was a brilliant
refreshment
but there are agencies
gcsb no no no no
the gsb cb told us about there are
external
organizations that will come around and
test your system they come in they know
nothing about
what's what what's in the system they
just test to see where they can breach
and he said that's something we need to
do we can't assume that because we've
got
people like it managers working the
system and maybe been there for many
years get very familiar with the system
and don't see the cracks that can get
into there's no system fail safe but he
did say there was an organization like
michael no potentially what it was it's
an organization that goes around and
they just come in cold and they check
your system and he said that would be
well worth us doing that
can you remember the name model
very self chair um apologies i can't
remember the name but we do have um
another company that does
do checks in relation to that so we've
we're working regionally on our um
cyber threat
in relation to our technology um hence
why they when you look at this from a
risk perspective the inherent risk is a
lot lower um the
residual risk is a lot lower and that's
because of the controls and mitigations
we've got in place in relation to that
and the checks that we are doing on a
really regular basis we do get a quite a
number of attacks
as most entities do
and we're due for a cyber risk update at
the next risk insurance
i thought it was interesting that the
government advisor said that it's not
just criminals in russia doing this he
said you get inadvertent risk as well
and he alluded to things like our
procurement policy might
where we're interfacing with somebody on
a tender may leave the door open that
the third party can then zoom in or a
staff member that's scooting around the
system but lazy can also
compromise as well so they're the sorts
of risks that we need to
get on top of i guess
thank you
there would appear to be no further
questions
again had asked
for remove to receive the risk
management update report and note the
risk examples and information provided
by the pro map risk module
thank you graeme thank you nobody all
those in favor please say aye
against abstentions carried
thank you peter thank you
committee work program michael
thank you through this uh yourself the
chair i'll take this uh report is being
read it is
an update on what are the reports that
the councillors can expect to receive on
a quarterly basis uh you'll see it's
quite a full agenda
on every single risk and assurance
committee
with
one meeting to actually go over the
program for the year scheduled
going forward in august but we
needed to get this this one approved so
we've got clarity going into the new
year
open for questions thank you are there
any questions
appear to be straightforward
someone please move that we
receive the report and approve the risk
insurance in your work program for the
21 22. thank you rebecca thank you
nobody all those in favor please say aye
aye
against abstentions carried thank you
policy program
welcome
everybody patiently
kyoto um so i'll just take the report as
read this report provides the risk
insurance committee an update on where
we're at with the um
policy program which includes the
council's bylaws
um
so essentially we had a busy year around
the ltp updating a lot of policies that
um
were related to the ltp uh regulatory
required policies
and now that we have hayden powell talk
about the bylaws in a moment on deck
which we're very glad to have on board
um we can now turn our attention to some
of the other policies
um and make sure that council's in a
good position to ensure those are in
line with best practice that we're
identifying any gaps and we're updating
policies where they need to be updated
just to put council in the best position
possible
um so as i mentioned next year we'll be
busy for bylaws so hayden's just gonna
briefly speak to
that
yes thank you
good to go to everyone so you just
quickly it is very by-law centric
engagement calendar for next year we've
got eight in total on the horizon so
there is quite a few
and the engagement around those is quite
extensive so um there are some policies
that we do fit in around those
and all the other smaller ones we'll
deal with when we get some capacity as
well
of course it is subject to change
depending on how the program unfolds and
just quickly there are one or two that
we'll be trying to work with in
conjunction with sdc to make sure we try
and get some regional alignment where we
can do as well
thank you darren
thanks chair um
really just checking to see if we will
look for opportunities where we can
consult on more than one bylaw
at a time for example i think last time
we did the dog control by law with
keeping of animals
birds and poultry bees
will we look to do that again
absolutely yes so when we do the dog
control by law we also do the keeping
animals by law
and later in the year when we get to the
water supply by law we'll do the
probably do the cobra practice at the
same time that is reliant on aligning
with sdc's processes
thank you thanks
are there any other questions
it would appear to be none
uh so again thank you for your report
please ask someone to
move that we received the report on
bylaws and policies review process uh we
note the engagement calendar for 2022
and the policy schedule
and note the electronic access
acceptable use
for staff and the acceptable use for
non-staff
someone please move thank you rebecca
thank you darren all those in favor
please say hi
against abstentions carried thank you
both for your work
financial risks
update
patricia back on
okay so this is the new report um
and it's kind of cover
sensitive expenditure will probably end
up in this one as well
so
this covers our treasury
and debt management
um this month
from a treasury perspective
we've got the bangkok report for
september quarter
there's a little bit of additional
commentary in the report which i'll take
is read about what's happening but
um
councillors should note because we've
got a
borrowing is fixed
we still
have the benefit of quite low interest
rates and we have one of the lowest cost
of borrowings across the sector
and that will continue into next year as
well but we are watching the markets
quite closely
um though the recommendation at the
moment is not to go and take out any
more board extra um
board interest rate contracts to lock in
any
rates um the other point around treasury
is that we have had our annual review
from fitch our credit raters and they
have confirmed our credit rating as a
double a plus um with a stable outlook
which is good
and that allows
us to
continue to borrow at the same levels
and that um writing action commentaries
included within the paper as well
now on debt management um this is
something i'm not sure councillors have
had visibility of previously
um
we have done this as at the end of
october
with the amount of debt outstanding in
both rates
and from as normal business operations
so dogs building
their charges down at um at the tip
so the table
on page my board books will give me the
page it won't
and the report shows that at october we
had
4.4 million
outstanding and sundry debt this is
without rates
a lot of that has now since been paid um
but um
and we're going to continue to monitor
that
we haven't proposed any write-offs as
yet
as we continue to manage through that
rates debtors
at that same period we've done it in
november
before the latest installment
and it showed we had one just over a
million outstanding it related to 747
ratepayers
predominantly um
spread actually even between how much
they owe but
365 of those owned nearly a million
dollars in rates
collectively collectively yes
um currently we've got nine properties
where we're at summary judgment in the
district court for
um
and there's a further property we're an
abandoned land sale
as being processed through the courts so
we do process through we have um powers
under the local government rating act
to collect and we utilize those to their
fullest extent
any questions
just a couple of questions um
the the double a plus rating
um
any other council's got that rating are
you aware of
um
i'm i'm not off the top of my head sorry
council i think last time we had at one
stage we had a double a minus and there
were only three in the country
so we're probably leading the pack which
is a great result for the council around
around our net debt balance
um
when you consider what other councils
are declaring in relation to their three
waters capacity to fund it
they've got no
no buying capacity which we've got which
is which is excellent i guess
for yourself the chair um
and and just in response to that there
are very few others that have got that
rating so i can confirm that there are
only a few that are at double a plus
because i think we we had a report i
think
going back a few months oh might have
been a couple of meetings ago where
there was an alternative rating used and
it was confusing because it threw us in
with a whole lot of other stuff and the
rating was nothing like that but that's
the other issue i guess is does that
rating affect their ability to borrow
off lgfa
um
yes it does um so depending on your
credit rating as your additional
spread they add to the base rank oh
that's great thank you
thank you
um can you hear me yes
ross yes bruce go
for some reason my picture isn't coming
through but i don't think that's any uh
any particular problem for you guys
um look can i just say too nobby that
look this is a good result and be
careful
um there are definitely a lot of
councils with double a ratings but the
plus size is really super
different situations with different
councils of course um the big boys up
north have got substantial headless
growth
um i was just interested patricia in the
advice
not to take a fixed position in the
market so we've got 10 million dollars
falling due
on april 2022 is that correct what what
is our strategy for that
um
that i think is that it will be repaid
out of surplus cash at the moment
um right
the the concern is that the market is
still quite volatile
and weather and that was we're due to
have another update with the advisor as
into whether that volatility is now
stabled but it was at the point when he
would break that that was moving weekly
yeah yeah yeah
look it just depends when you want what
makes you want to buy your bonds i guess
um and the different strategies but
actually i've heard this similar advice
elsewhere as well um so
it certainly
is it's good to get a report like this
prediction it's one that we'll need to
monitor because
there is substantial challenge to to our
overall cost of firing i'm only stating
the obvious
no other questions
would appear to be none thank you
patricia does someone please move that
we received the financial risks update
report and note the information thank
you darren thank you nobody all those in
favor please say i
i
against abstentions carried
that concludes the
public session could i please ask
or a move that we now move to public
excluded have a second to please
thank you rebecca boys in favor please
say aye all right
again extension's carried i'll just wait
for a moment now for